so after careful consideration we have
decided that
from tomorrow to be reviewed every three
weeks and with exceptions that i will
come on to
visiting other households will not be
permitted to be clear this extends the
restriction
that has been in place across the west
of scotland for the past three weeks to
all of scotland
regulations giving effect to this change
will come into force on friday but i'm
asking people to comply
from tomorrow one of the reasons we have
decided to do this
is that our early data suggests that
this restriction
is starting to slow the increase of
cases in the west of scotland
so if we take the difficult decision to
extend it nationwide now
in an early and preventative way we hope
it will help to bring the r number down
and divide us back under control there
will be exceptions for those living
alone or alone with children who form
extended households
for couples in non-cohabiting
relationships for the provision of
informal child care by for example
grandparents
and for trades people but for everyone
else visiting each other's houses will
for now not be
permitted these new restrictions apply
to people's homes in other words to
private
indoor spaces rules for meeting other
people in public
indoor spaces that are subject to strict
regulation and guidance
remain the same you can meet with one
other household only
and in groups of no more than six people
as i said earlier we will be working
with local authorities
to strengthen inspection and enforcement
in indoor public places
and enforcement action including closure
if necessary will be taken
against shops pubs restaurants or other
premises that do not ensure compliance
you can also continue to meet with one
other household in groups of up to six
people
outdoors including in private gardens
outdoors though we intend
to exempt children under 12 both from
the limit of six
and the limit of two households there
will be no limits on the ability of
children under 12 to play together
outdoors and young people aged 12 to 18
will be exempt from the two household
limit they will be able to meet together
outdoors in groups of up to six though
we will need to monitor
this carefully and let me stress this is
outdoors only
and let me say to teenagers in
particular
i know how miserable this is for you and
i am so grateful for your patience
we are trying to give you as much
flexibility as we can
at this vitally important time of your
lives
in return please work with us and do
your best to stick to the rules
for everyone's sake presenting officer
the last new restriction i want to cover
today relates to traveling by car it may
seem minor but it is important
we know again from test and protect data
that sharing
car journeys presents a significant risk
of transmission
we're therefore advising against car
sharing with people outside
your own household finally i think it's
important that i indicate today
in light of the current situation that
the route map changes with an
indicative date of 5th october are
unlikely now to go ahead on that
timescale
signing officer i also want to touch
briefly today on an issue that has been
the subject of media speculation in
recent days namely the possibility of a
so-called circuit breaker
time to coincide with the october school
break and during which people would be
given
much more comprehensive advice to stay
at home
the scottish government has not made any
decision at this stage to implement such
a policy however we are actively keeping
it under review
what i would say to people now is this
please think of the october break as an
opportunity to
further limit social interaction
particularly indoors
and given that this is a global pandemic
please
do not book travel overseas for the
october break if it is not essential
finally i want to say a few words to
people who are shielding and
are we're shielding rather earlier in
the year i know you will all be feeling
particularly anxious
however the best way to keep you safe is
by reducing the spread of the virus in
our communities which is what today's
measures are all about
the steps i have outlined today will
help keep you safe so please follow the
guidance for the general population with
great care
and if you haven't signed up for our
text alert service please do so
fundamentally i want to assure you that
your safety is uppermost in our minds
but we do not believe that asking you to
return to shielding is the best way to
secure it
given the impact it would have on your
mental and physical health
in our view all of us acting together
collectively to reduce the spread of the
virus is a better way to keep you safe
citing officer these are the changes we
are making now i can't
and will not rule out the need to make
more nationally or locally in the weeks
to come suppressing the virus and
getting
are below one again is essential and we
will act in a way that can
achieve that indeed we will publish soon
an overall strategic approach to
escalation in areas with particularly
high rates of transmission
however i am acutely aware that the
restrictions i have announced today
will not be welcome but it is our
judgment that they are absolutely
essential
inevitably some will think they go too
far and others will think they don't go
far enough but we have tried to get the
balance as right as possible
and to act urgently and in a substantial
and preventative way now to try to get
the situation under control quickly
we judge that this will give us the best
chance of avoiding tougher or longer
lasting measures later
but i know that doesn't make this any
easier many people
me included will find not being able to
have family and friends in our own homes
really difficult especially
as the weather gets colder but today's
measures a little tough are not
a lockdown they are carefully targeted
at key sources of transmission and we
believe they can make a significant
difference
while keeping our schools public
services and as many businesses as
possible open
however the success of these measures
depends on all of us the decisions that
we all make as individuals in the weeks
ahead will determine whether they work
and how quickly they can be lifted that
fact isn't just a reminder of the
responsibilities we all owe to each
other
it's also a reminder that we are not
powerless against this virus
none of us can guarantee that we won't
get it or pass it on but we can all make
choices
that significantly reduce our own risk
and help keep our communities safer
so please make these choices stick with
this
please don't meet people in their homes
or your home because that is where the
virus often spreads
limit how often you meet up with people
in public places and abide by the rules
enforced there
work from home if you can follow the
advice on self-isolation if you have
symptoms test positive
or are a contact of someone with the
virus download the protect scotland app
and when you do meet other people
remember facts at all times
face coverings avoid crowded places
clean your hands and surfaces keep a two
meter distance from other households
and self-isolate and book a test if you
have symptoms